it's safe to say you guys have got the
memo that fallout 4 metal gear solid 5
the phantom pain black ops 3 Assassin's
Creed syndicate and halo 5 are all
coming this year but I thought I'd spend
this week telling you about five other
awesome games that are also arriving in
2015 if waiting is really not your thing
the next week you can check out
PlayStation 4 exclusive everybody's gone
to the rapture developed by the Chinese
room who previously made amnesia a
machine for pigs and di Resta
everybody's gone to the rapture will
combine the atmosphere and exploration
of diresta with the exploration and
interactions of amnesia it's not just
walking anymore everybody's gone to the
rapture is set in the big open world of
shropshire during the apocalypse and
will feature six characters who each
have their own stories if you like
exploring really pretty worlds and
making in-game decisions that actually
matter you can play this on August 11 it
has been a really long wait on this one
but it seems like Avalanche Studios Mad
Max may be well worth your time since
rocket League has gotten everybody in
the mood for driving about you may as
well up the ante and trade that soccer
ball the generous destruction and lethal
weaponry the majority of the game will
call for you to explore the open-world
in your customizable car magnum opus and
survive the apocalyptic wasteland by
scavenging and defeating enemies on both
foot and in your car if you thought
shadow of mordor could have done with
more guns car and desert Mad Max might
serve up what you're after come
September switching from fast cars too
fast guitar solos rock band or is going
to give you a reason to hang out with
your friends in real life when it comes
out in October harmonics are bringing
the critically-acclaimed rhythm game
series back with its first major release
in five years rock band 4 is promising
to get back to the core gameplay of the
franchise and features new in
provides a shin mechanics for all
instruments so you can add some personal
expression to the songs you play
Harmonix has said that all of your
previously purchased DLC from over the
years will be compatible with the new
game Harmonix have also said that while
new hardware is being designed for the
ps4 and Xbox one the game will be
backwards compatible with your old rock
band guitar and drum controllers if you
miraculously have any that aren't
totally broken this next game adrift is
one of the coolest VR experiences that
I've personally played and you can pick
it up on all new generations hat forms
when it comes out in September adrift is
basically the VR space game you've been
thinking about since you were a kid and
looking down past your virtual feet to
the surface of the earth is exactly as
terrifying as you'd expect in a drift
you'll have to explore the innards and
outsides of a space station solving
puzzles and working out what happened to
the crew while keeping an eye on your
oxygen levels in order to keep things
from going full Sandra Bullock in
gravity basically you want to stay alive
uncover audio logs and try to return
home safely it's being developed by 310
and led by Adam orth best known as the
microsoft guy that told everybody who
was complaining about Xbox one's
online-only functionality to deal with
it all said that adrift was directly
conceived as a result of his dismissal
over the incident so given how good the
game looks maybe things didn't go so
badly for him after all alternatively
you could keep your feet planted firmly
on the floor with rise of the Tomb
Raider so long as you have an xbox one
rise of the Tomb Raider continues the
story from the first game but with a
much more hardened and experienced Laura
which makes sense given she had plenty
of experience in falling off very high
places very frequently in 2013 reboot
rise of the Tomb Raider is going to have
a day-night cycle a crafting system like
the last game unfortunately more actual
rating of two's game is lucky enough to
have an xbox one will get to crack back
into Lara's adventures in November
whereas the rest
bus will have to wait it out until 2016
of course the rest of us can just play
fallout 4 in the meantime since that's
up on the same day let me know down in
that comment box which games you are
most excited to play this year and I
will catch you again next week